Wie ein riesiges Wespennest:
So sieht es aus, wenn sich einmal im Jahr
tausende Vespisti treffen,
um ihrer Vespa-Leidenschaft zu frönen –
dieses Jahr im ungarischen Zánka,
einem 800-Seelen-Dorf
am nördlichen Ufer des Plattensees.
Wir kommen aus der Gegend von Nürnberg.
Wir kommen aus Bukarest.
Mir san von Österreich.
Aus Belgien.
Aus Melbourne.
Tokio. Tokio, Japan.
Wir wohnen in Manchester.
Ich komme aus Bali in Indonesien.
Ich komme aus Udine in Italien.
Einige Teilnehmer haben für die World Vespa
Days eine lange Reise auf sich genommen –
so wie der Vespa Club München.
Ab nach Ungarn.
Nach zwei Tagen und rund 600 Kilometern
sind sie pünktlich
zum Festivalstart eingetroffen.
Für vier Tage
brummt und knattert es hier an jeder Ecke.
Die Gemeinde der Vespisti
ist groß und international.
Fahrer aus mehr als 40 Ländern
sind dieses Jahr mit dabei.
Die Motivation ist bei jedem eine andere.
Einfach die alte Zeit am Leben halten und das
Ganze genießen, die Renaissance der Roller.
Es ist eine Lebensweise.
Man lernt gute Freunde kennen.
Wir haben viel Spaß.
Und am wichtigsten ist, dass wir diese Woche
ohne unsere Frauen sind.
Und die Vespa World Days sind für uns
immer ’ne gute Gelegenheit,
Europa kennenzulernen,
das Land und die Menschen.
Für mich ist es meine Religion,
meine Leidenschaft.
Ich denke,
es ist das Gefühl von Freiheit.
Mit dem Zweitakter auf und davon –
darauf freuen sich hier alle.
55 Kilometer liegen
bei der heutigen Tour vor den 60 Rollern.
Die Strecke führt durchs Hinterland
entlang kleiner Dörfer,
Obstplantagen und Rebstöcken.
Der Weinanbau hat in der Region Tradition.
Die meisten Vespas sind älter als ihre Fahrer.
Wer eine besitzt,
sollte handwerklich begabt sein.
Es wird getüftelt und gefachsimpelt.
Die Vespaparade ist für viele
der knapp 5000 Besucher der Höhepunkt.
Auf dem Festivalgelände heißt es:
sehen und gesehen werden.
Hier wird von früh bis spät
ausgelassen gefeiert.
Konzerte heizen die Stimmung an.
Und was natürlich nicht fehlen darf:
der Auftritt der Vespa-Akrobatik-Gruppe
aus München – eine der besten der Welt.
Geleitet wird sie von Robin Davy
alias Mister Vespa.
Viva la Vespa!
Die Disziplin hat ihre Anfänge
in den 1950er-Jahren.
Die Münchener Enthusiasten lassen die in
Vergessenheit geratene Kunstform
seit 1995 wieder aufleben – zum
eigenen Vergnügen und dem des Publikums.
Wir waren heute richtig gut drauf
und die Piste war ja ’n bisschen buckelig.
War auch mal ’n Gullydeckel dazwischen.
Super! Wir haben ... wir sind super gefahren.
Dafür sind wir Akrobaten,
weil ... die Gullys, die machen uns nichts aus.
Nächstes Jahr gibt es die erste Ausgabe
der Vespa World Days in Asien,
und zwar auf Bali in Indonesien.